There is a little bit of different solution this inequality. We could add 2 in
our answer now, so we need a different way of writing the answer in a set of
parenthesis. We're going to use brackets. We use a bracket to indicate that the
variable x could take on that value. The same is true on the number line. x can
now equal to, so we put a bracket in set of a parenthesis. And again, notice I
have an open parenthesis for infinity. The interval is considered to be open on
this end, because we can always count higher to a number. We can't really reach
positive infinity, so we use a parenthesis. In general, for less than or equal
to signs and greater than or equal to signs, you will always use a bracket. For
less than and greater than, you'll use parentheses. And of course, parentheses
always go around positive infinity or negative infinity. Let's put these symbols
to use.